[Music]
happy thanksgiving
i'm julie chrisley and cookie has always
been a passion of mine
i've had a baking business i've worked
in kitchens and friends always ask for
my recipes this is your dream come true
i mean you are in your element and this
thanksgiving i'm making all my favorite
recipes but can i tell you how excited i
am that the kids are actually gonna help
are you actually sure that this is a
good idea i mean because i would like to
have a thanksgiving meal that i could
eat this year you all are gonna be
helping me uh no i was only invited to
eat
[Laughter]
so who's gonna take the innards out of
the turkey one two three
get it just get that oh my god you can't
make cornbread dressing without
cornbread huh chloe are you eyeing these
marshmallows girl yeah
[Music]
i'm a really chubby bunny i believe so
are you not gonna add a little brandy to
this we're not doing that with this one
it's a napkin savannah oh i thought that
was a placemat
now that smells like some good southern
cooking it looks so good
what are you doing i don't know i saw it
on tv once happy thanksgiving happy
thanksgiving happy thanksgiving
a lot of cooks in this kitchen we got to
say extra prayer for him
you